[Music]
it was a doomsday scenario on our
doorsteps
lockdowns cities deserted
travel disrupted the bonds that bind us
for millions it meant working from home
or else remote learning online exercise
it's been almost 18 months we know the
death toll we know the damage it did to
our economies
but what did being cut off from each
other due to our
mental well-being
welcome to our kobe 19 special i'm
monica jones good to have you with us
so how are you today coping with
all the pandemic restrictions well i
have to admit that
after the past 18 months i'm slightly
more on edge these days
and despite lower infection rates i'm
still hesitant about
meeting other people i wonder where this
will end
but if the pandemic can affect me what
must it be like for people
already struggling with anxieties
[Music]
out of his head and into his body
martin's drumsticks
are his anchor when everything around
him seems to fall apart
the 33 year old has suffered from
depression for years
but his illness has been at its worst
during the pandemic
everything crumbled his therapy the
structure of his daily life
his whole stability chapman
went to the park and tried to shut it
all out
it was just too much for me i didn't
want to see
or hear anything it feels like you're
getting sucked
into absolute emptiness and that doesn't
feel very nice
veronica finds peace in literature
reading poetry outside
she has also suffered from depression
for years but during the pandemic
the 23 year old became so depressed that
she needed hospital treatment
sometimes it was so bad that she could
no longer find any meaning in life
it's become analysis
my thoughts start going round in circles
i think about suicide
i have the urge to hurt myself that's
been part of my life for years
and i have very little motivation even
if i wanted to do something
i couldn't bring myself to do it
people suffering from depression are hit
particularly hard by the fears and
restrictions of the pandemic
also because therapies were often broken
off during lockdown
but the curbs on freedom also affect
people not suffering from clinical
depression
but experts do not see the pandemic in
itself
as a trigger for depression
people have definitely experienced
severe mood swings
but that doesn't mean that we will see a
new wave of patience with depression
the illness is quite separate from
external factors
that means if you don't have the
predisposition
you don't slip into it even if life has
been hard on you
veronica speaks openly on social media
about what she has gone through during
lockdown
about her suffering but also about her
successes
it has been a learning experience
i've learned to stand up for myself when
i have problems
if i feel uncomfortable i say so so that
something can be done about it
i've also learned to be more comfortable
on my own
it doesn't work for long but it's okay
for a few days
right now neither veronica nor martin
feel like being alone
martin's looking forward to getting back
together with his band soon
well for more on this i'm joined by
elise paul she's a senior research
fellow
in the research department of behavioral
science and health at university college
in london good to have you with us
let's just start straight away with what
we heard in this report uh
where it just showed that uh some
patients some people
that suffer from depression they've
turned to social media as a tool to
self-medicate when therapy
was not available do you think that
that's a good alternative
it certainly depends on what people are
using
social media for um if they are using it
to
disclose you know difficulties and seek
support that could be a positive thing
but if they're using it to sort of avoid
you know coping with their difficulties
then that could be a negative thing
we've also found that
excessive looking for new scrolling for
news on kovid
was related to declines in mental health
so it really does depend
how you're using social media
how well are therapies actually prepared
for dealing with the the additional
problems that their patients are
experiencing now because of the pandemic
well i think it's difficult to say as an
epidemiologist i can't speak on behalf
of therapists but i will
i would say that you know as therapists
are people too
even though we've all been impacted in
different ways we have all gone through
the pandemic together over the past year
and a half
um and there will be an increased need
for therapy
i hope that this will be an opportunity
for
governments policymakers um and even in
the general population
to pay more attention to mental health
and to
direct more resources in that direction
of course we've also heard in this
report that
while a lot of people obviously feeling
the weight of the pandemic i just
mentioned something myself there as well
that
cannot be compared to a real serious
clinical
depression so people sort of being moody
now
is that just a face or is there perhaps
the danger that they'll actually fall
into a proper depression
well i mean i think that it's important
to consider how
those mood swings and how the
irritability is affecting one's life
um if it is making it really difficult
to carry out your activities
things that you need to do if it's
impacting your work
your parenting your relationships then
it is important to seek help
you know whether or not you feel you
meet some clinical threshold i think
it's important to consider
how it is impacting one's life i mean
how do you
how do you notice how can you
differentiate also as an outsider
perhaps to see okay this person now is
really in danger of not just being
not just having a day off but actually
being being ill
well excessive days off from work are
certainly
uh one sign um another that friends and
family could notice
is avoidance behaviors so some people
tend to withdraw
and have some of the classic symptoms of
depression that we typically think of
such as sleeping too much
you know reduced energy slow moving
other people can have things like
irritability
you know lashing out a lot of anger so i
think it can
it is important to acknowledge that it
can look different
in different people you mentioned uh
something else about these of um
awareness of mental
mental illness is is has risen now
because of that
that could actually be a good thing an
upside to the pandemic or am i reading
too much into that
no i think it's definitely a good thing
i hope that will come out of this
pandemic
i think that you know it's just
unprecedented that we've been cut off
from things that we enjoy art you know
we've gotten the opportunity to think
about what is the difference between
attending a concert live versus seeing
it online
what's it like to be in a room with five
of your friends versus
on a walk on a rainy day with one of
your friends and so we've really
had the opportunity to think about and
as researchers too and to study
what is it about our daily lives that is
necessary
to maintain mental health um you know
whether or not we've slipped into a
depression but just on a daily basis
all right and last question a personal
one how do you
cope with the pressure of the pandemic
yeah so i try to do things every day
that just keep my body and mind
able to cope the best i can i drink lots
of water
i try to go to bed every night at the
same time wake up at the same time
i eat healthy i watch my caffeine and
alcohol intake
i exercise every day and i also meditate
every day i have meditation apps on my
phone
even if it's just five minutes in the
morning it really helps me to
internalize
a calm meaning right good good advice
thank you so much elise poor senior
research fellow and the research
department of behavioral science and
health
at university college in london
time for your questions now and over to
derek
[Music]
how can genetic engineering be helpful
in fighting upcoming pandemics
genetic engineering is one of those
phrases that get thrown around a lot but
i found a
a surprising number of people don't
actually know what it means so so let's
define it
before moving forward when you
genetically engineer something you use
tools from fields that are usually now
grouped under the label
biotechnology to manipulate
and modify an organism's genome
the goal is to make it do things the
organism
wouldn't do otherwise for example
produce
a highly specific medicinal product or
produce it
in faster ways or produce it in larger
amounts
genetic engineering methods are now
common in areas
from from crop science to waste
mitigation
to sustainable fuel development but when
it comes to modern
medicine genetically modified
microorganisms play a really
central role nowadays for instance
microbes have been engineered to churn
out
much of the insulin that people with
diabetes
need to survive and and gene editing
methods are also key
to designing new medications they're
used not only
to manufacture a complex biologics like
like monoclonal antibodies but but also
vaccines
viral vector vaccines like those made by
astrazeneca
are like like poster child examples of
products made
with genetic engineering they work
because the designers were able to
splice
genes from stars cov2 into a harmless
adenovirus that that when injected
can help make you immune to covet 19. so
genetic engineering is much more than
helpful in the fight against pandemics
it'll continue to be a
crucial facet of reacting to them
and containing them in the future
thanks for watching